I'm truly sooo about the female
characters in the film cause it's easy
to blame the man and just say oh well
he's a dog or he's a playwright it takes
two to tango so what are the female
characters like in this phone well
you've got two main female characters
the first is Sophie who is the character
that kind of brings Tyler around like he
falls for her very quickly and she she
sees right through him and basically
calls him on his his tacky ways and you
know I think that's he says in the film
that she's his real type like you have
two types of people that you date the
type of person you date somebody who's
just outside of what you want so you can
be at ease yet dissatisfied and never
really feel like uncomfortable nervous
or self-conscious but move on Sophie's
the real time she's the one that when he
hangs out with her he doesn't want to
blow it he is less cool because he's
trying harder you know what I mean and
she I think is going through her own
issues of does she doesn't want to give
away power you know she doesn't want to
fall for somebody you know she's in a
relationship with a guy who maybe is not
perfect for her but it's safe and at the
same time there's another character
played by the Ness branch who is
basically Tyler's equal and they're both
single and having this a very casual
sexual relationship that is you know
kind of his longest romantic
relationship to date and it's
meaningless but they're both very
pragmatic about you know their what
their relationship is so who are they I
don't
I don't know everybody sort of feels in
control like yeah everyone's fighting
for control the whole time I think
everybody is and I think that's true in
dating too it's like you know you want
to be happy but also don't want to be a
you know a victim you don't want someone
else to be control of your happiness I
don't know I think it's it's a constant
you know tug and I can't think the
expression pulling tugging but I don't
know but it's you know it's not easy
nothing's easy about love and I think
the whole dance that you go through is
really interesting and I know I haven't
seen many movies about it to be honest
like most of the movies that you see
about this kind of stuff are really
silly they're not the way people act at
all you know this was a big studio
rom-com you know Matthew McConaughey
would be playing me and he'd be that guy
who's lovable he's a lovable CAD you
know but the truth is Tyler is flawed
he's a flawed person and I like the
reality that I like dealing with the
realities of dating because I think it's
much more interesting than somebody
jumping on a horse and racing across the
Brooklyn Bridge to stop a wedding it's
about to happen because that doesn't
happen ever ever - how do you think the
film will play in sort of the Middle
States where everybody's bound by
getting married by a certain age and you
settle down with that highschool
sweetheart yeah versus the two coasts
where everybody's oh oh I don't know and
they're doing their own thing and fun
yeah it's a good question I'll let you
know because we open in Shreveport
Louisiana which is my hometown where we
shot the film as well that's June 15th
but you know I don't know my last film
weather girl was much more palatable you
know he's very it pays off in all the
ways that you want you know romantic
comedy to pay off I think it's a little
better than your average
you know romantic comedy but that's I'm
biased obviously but this one is a
little less of that it's a little
harsher and it's Tyler has teeth that
was one of the things that we kept in
the editing room it would be very easy
to make him to lose the
again the reality to lose the teeth you
know it's like no he's kind of a selfish
and it's like we need to show that we
don't show that we're not being true and
then the movie doesn't work so I don't
know we'll see III I hope they like it
yeah what kind of feedback have you
received from both men and women like me
me privately right they can find it a
gene and you like that's me or that was
my ax or son absolutely I think one of
the one of the greatest things about the
festival circuit that we've just gone
through is after the movie everybody has
an opinion everybody wants to talk about
you know how the movie ends and you know
who they like and they don't like and
what whether this should have worked out
of this should but it's a conversation
and I think that if you go to this movie
on a date you're gonna talk to whoever
you're with for a while about what it
means and what you know who you related
to or like this guy was a jerk but you
know he came around but then what about
this guy I don't know I think I think
there's a lot to talk about
and I think it encourages discourse
which as a filmmaker it's really
satisfying I know we talked to a
gentleman that did a doc on online
dating and they said everybody has a
pattern and in who they choose so what
were some of the patterns in this
relation in this movie like that the
Germaine character was always choosing
the same type of line yeah well that's
true innate we touched on it a little
bit a minute ago where it's like it's a
girl who's almost exactly what you want
but not enough to actually make your
life more difficult
which you know is it kind of a coward's
way out isn't it but that is his pattern
and in a way it's it's Sophie played by
Natalie Morales it's it's her pattern as
well to get something that's safe and
comfy so she is nesting but he is just
ending every relationship after a couple
of months because you know what
difference does it make you know why
make the sacrifice all the sacrifices
that come with being in a relationship
if you know it's just going to end and
you know you'll get over it
no I mean yeah yeah it's a it's a flawed
theory unlike but I think a lot of
people have flawed theories they're just
not as it's structured like he's you
know it's like you can look at the rules
and you can be on what this is a dumb
rule
well Tyler and like yeah but I have had
people who haven't seen the movie like
on Twitter or something like that say oh
man this is ridiculous you never have
rules for dating that's you know that
that's the worst way to get anything
through I think that's a lie I think
everybody has rules you know whether
it's a you know don't have sex until the
third date or it's you know don't date
somebody that isn't that has a job that
requires them to work 18 hours a day
don't date long-distance these are rules
these are little bitty guidelines that
we in our experience of dating have
decided this is not for me you know and
I think everybody can relate to having
these little guidelines on how to date
just like you were saying about the guy
who made the dock it's like everybody's
got their own thing but we all have a
thing well women there's a series of
book books called the rules yeah and it
teaches us I shouldn't be revealing you
see don't let the guy know that you're
available clean that you have a calendar
that you need to check right you play
very unavailable what are some of these
things that men do that that you might
be able to share well I think for for
Tyler specifically it's not letting it
go too far like you know he don't give
flowers or anything like that it sends
the wrong message don't spend the night
you know watch out for the band guy this
a band guy shows up he's almost
assuredly gonna take the girl from you
because you guys are suckers for a guy
in a band yeah yeah but you know it just
is little things like that you know and
like I think one of the main themes of
the movie is for Tyler is that you know
friendship is the most important thing
the friendship that he has you know with
Martin stars character Allen in this it
is the heart of the movie it's a you see
the humanity in Tyler through his
relationship with this dude you know
that is lacking in his you know casual
relationships with women
you